What's up guys, today we are back and we are fulfilling a request that came out of the comments from Phil R. who says...
"Freeze the heart in liquid nitrogen then smash it into pieces... just like my ex did."
Phil I'm sorry to hear about your misfortune but a lot of people but a lot of people are supporting your comment...
So that's the experiment that we are trying today.
Now, you properly recognize this heart from the casting experiment we did where we cloned it in chocolate,
and made a 2 pound solid chocolate heart for Valentine's Day.
That was pretty awesome but Valentine's Day is over. So I get a big thermos of my own home-made liquid nitrogen,
a glass jar from our vacuum chamber experiments, and a wide variety of tools,
so we can chip into this thing and dissect it "King of Random" style.
Now I'm no biology expert, so I printed off a little reference guide here,
that we can use to figure out exactly what we're hacking into, and maybe we'll learn something,
about how the heart works as we do.
So looking at these pictures here you can see this is kinda like a mirror image of the heart,
so right here we have the,
right atrium, the right ventricle, and over here we got the left ventricle, and the left atrium,
and then up here we have our arteries and valves,
apparently these little things here are small muscles that are from when the heart developed,
and they don't really seem to serve a purpose,
so let's go ahead and transfer liquid nitrogen into the jar first,
hopefully our glass jar doesn't crack from thermal shock,
'cause if it does were gonna be wasting alooot of nitrogen,
nitrogen is interesting stuff like as this glass cools down to temperature it actually does this rapid boil at the end,
where we get little bits spilling out everywhere,
which is too bad because this stuff is really precious and hard to make,
alright little heart you have served us well, its time to meet your Frosty Fate,
here we go,
oh yeah,
I always forget about this, theres like this nitrogen vapor there,
and whenever something warm touches it,
it like creates this little force field that is super cool!
that is nuts! hehe,
it's like ripples in the ocean except it's nitrogen vapors,
how cool is that? It's not even touching the nitrogen yet,
here we go!
aaand we have contact.
[Sizzling sound]
what's really is funny as you can still see little bits of the red chocolate and theres even some  blue silicone.
from when we poured the mold stuck down inside one of these arteries.
well it's been about two minutes there let's just see how the outside of the heart is looking.
oh yeah that's a little frosty.
[Thuds]
it's as hard as a rock.
[Thud]
now a heart of this size, I imagine is gonna take at least ten to twenty minutes to freeze all the way through,
because although the outside is freezing solid there is so much mass to this heart,
that it's gonna take quite a bit of time for the cold to penetrate all the way through,
and I would like this to be completely frozen by the time we start chipping into it,
so let's just go ahead and plop it down into the nitrogen and let it sit for 20 minutes,
oh wow my tongs got stuck,
okay I'm just gonna dip this in by hand and we'll see how much nitrogen this displaces,
you can already see its starting to boil out the top,
and that's because that heart is so warm,
the nitrogen is going crazy,
and I don't want to loose too much of it so i gotta do this,
kinda slowly here let the heart settle in,
look at this,
uh oh,
there it goes that was an accident darn it -ahahaha,
and there goes the nitrogen,
[Thud]
WOW that froze up quick look at this,
the artery is already solid, right there,
that's already solid,
about half my nitrogen just spilled out,
so we're gonna try this again a little bit slower,
and as that boils down we'll just keep it topped up with nitrogen,
and give it about twenty minutes to set.
*music*
so side note I actually made this liquid nitrogen I've got a generator that took a couple of years to set up,
but it's finally working,
and this is the first batch of homemade liquid nitrogen,
that I've actually put to use,
and it looks like it's doing a good job.
I mean it's working! Homemade liquid nitrogen guys!
video coming soon,
alright so update guys it as been twenty minutes that our heart has been sitting  in,
a bath of liquid nitrogen, let's take a peak inside,
and see if anythings changed.
Here we go, oh look at that guys, it has cracked,
you can see it's cracked
right through the right ventricle,
and it split over into the left ventricle and the left atrium.
There is a possibility that that is from when I was dropping it,
I was a little bit to abusive with this thing,
but I didn't see any cracks initially.
these have all popped up in the last 10 minutes.
So the question on my mind right now is after 20 minutes in liquid nitrogen, is this thing frozen completely solid, or is there still some gummy meaty tissue on the inside.
there is only one way to find out, so lets grab a hammer and a chisel and begin chipping away at it.
That is frosty,